this puppy came for the milk taste test
I've had many types of milk but I've
never had dogs milk I would never drink
a glass of milk ah I would I drink milk
every day
do you like mode um it's sort of milk
kinda like fixing eyes and go out of soy
milk you guys party it'll be good to
find out if I'm glad it smells like a
barn it's not heavier dreamy Oh
something really depressed produce this
no I do think goats are also weirdly
like the children and spawn of Satan
it's got that bitterness to it that like
goat cheese head have you seen a goat
eye up close their pupils are
rectangular I can't do it again I can't
drink any more
this is goat's milk and it's very good
and you just never wanted to lick a goat
that almost smells like cookie dough oh
that's Walt's got a sweet yeah fruity
did you milk the teats of a fruit bag so
sweet oh it tastes like a melted
soft-serve that's been deleted twice
what about this is milk white soy water
cane sugar vanilla extract I guess it
the vanilla taste um a fake this black
seed milk I like it delicious I drink
more I don't like this smell this is
smells like another animal milk smells
cheesy yeah I got a chunk immediately
ohms like it nope
I mean it doesn't taste bad but you
saying that you had a chunk means I'm
done this tastes like liquid mac and
cheese there's a certain distant
staleness to this and I know she could
milk I mean I make sense they have
babies but like I don't think I like
milk I came into this test loving milk
you hated milk and now I hate meal our
final milk it looks almost like like
white paint I don't have any floater
this one smells heavy what is this
up for me now tastes like a corn husk
it's like crap
it's like grass there's a millisecond
for which is okay then there's some
horrible woulda SH taste that's weirder
has like a texture to it there's no way
this will get you high right I don't
know for the heck milk first
I'm amazed at ability to make milk out
of anything when we were kids we only
had one milk and from the cow
my question is how competitive is the
fake milk industry don't know I guess
I'll stick to like soy milk no like
there seems to be just like a lot of
different companies are they
neck-and-neck who's on top this is a
milk you drink after a hard day's work
come home you stand over your fireplace
you swirl the look at a tumbler you
regret your life decisions while you
married barber so young how can you
drink this round